so there are a few jobs in the world
that are more fun than being the head of
urban development for a great and
thriving City I mean it's just cities
are magical things you know the the
energy in them I mean you just have to
walk the streets and any borough here
and and you can see you you know between
what was in this city in the nineteen
some of these and where it is today and
how much more energy there is and how
much more just sheer we're going to get
through it we're going to do it we're
going to build it we're going to I mean
it's really neat when that fails when
you get a Detroit when the average price
of a house in Detroit last year was
about seven thousand bucks for houses
sold there's the opposite effect so
being head of an urban development
corporation for sitting like Mexico is a
wonderful job because you get to build
National Children's be in the National
Zoo the National auditorium at tech city
of 400,000 people it's a nifty place to
set it's much harder to do that job
today because drugs and insecurity have
become so prevalent because other
countries have moved so far ahead and
technology and we haven't changed the
education system because we in Mexico
bet on the United States for about
ninety percent of our exports while
Brazil and others diversified into Asia
and into Europe and frankly we haven't
been able to generate the jobs that keep
people at work now in the US the
interesting thing is happening is you're
beginning to get these it's not a flat
world it's a world that to quote Richard
Florida is getting very spiky there are
certain zip codes that generate a
disproportionate share of patents of
startups of wealth of jobs and it's
really important if other parts of the
country are going to want to create
these tech centers want to create these
life science cities these digital cities
that they begin to understand what the
ecosystem looks like what the different
pieces that you put together look like
what has to happen in that city
because it isn't you build a building it
isn't you put some money behind venture
there is a massive ecosystem that has to
get built that looks like a biosphere
and the various parts of that biosphere
better be there
New York City is a fascinating place
because it's very good at using the
energy and attracting some of the best
and the brightest from everywhere the
housing crisis may not be the worst
thing that's happened to New York City
because it was becoming impossible for
some of the young doctors for some of
the young artists for some of the people
that make this city so special to be
able to live here one of the lessons
that I hope people take out of this is
the extreme dependence simply on the
financial sector is really dangerous and
it can begin to look like Detroit
because as you recall the 1960s the
dominant technology leaders business
people on the planet lived in Detroit
but if you depend on a single industry
if you don't continuously upgrade it if
that industry is not producing real
wealth if it's simply shuffling paper
from here to here in a very efficient
manner sometimes that's not enough and
that's not where you begin to get the
rest of your job so it is important that
New York in addition to its fashion and
finance and tourism and communications
infrastructure also begin to develop a
venture infrastructure that's for real
you know you don't see the same number
of startups in New York City in
Manhattan certainly not in the borough's
even though you have the basic input
which is these extraordinary brains at
Columbia at Rockefeller at City
University of New York at NYU you have a
core of these brains that should be
generating startups in robotics startups
in nano technology startups in life
sciences you don't see the same type of
energy that you're seeing Cambridge Mass
or that you're seeing in San Diego or
that you're seeing in parts of Silicon
Valley and and this overwhelming
dominance of the financial sector if
that gets reinforced post this crisis
it's dangerous for New York and if there
isn't some sort of regulation on this
financial system it's also dangerous for
the u.s. in the world